[Music]
Luke and Jake here at the outdoor boys
YouTube channel and today we're doing
another axe restoration video now if
you've noticed behind me we've done a
few of these videos in the past and I
have a handful of axe heads that I have
been meaning to restore for years but
they're really nice ones and so I've
kind of been saving them waiting to get
a little bit more experience a little
bit more practice because I really
wanted to do them right but I think I'm
ready to jump into one of those projects
so today we're going to be restoring one
of my favorite bearded axes there we go
check this out this is the bearded axe I
want to restore this week I got it from
a guy in the Eastern Europe nice clean
lines there's a lot of different ways to
restore an axe but basically what I need
to do is remove the rust get rid of the
Knicks and the dings and I've used a lot
of different techniques in my videos -
naval jelly a vapor Russ electrolysis
coca-cola vinegar wire brushes angle
grinder sandpaper we're gonna use a
mixture of techniques today
[Music]
these $10 magnets from Harbor Freight
really are useful for these types of
projects not just holding your work
those are cleaning up
[Music]
well I've got about four or five hours
into this project I think I need a
little dinner break you want to see how
I make this griddle and how to make some
killer cheese steak sandwiches check out
that video and I'll put a link in the
description
[Applause]
[Music]
well it's another day and we've got
ourselves one shiny nice look at axe
head now making it all polish like this
isn't just for looks it helps protect it
from rust the more polished a metal
surface is the more impervious it is to
rust and corrosion all right so we've
got two axe heads one's rusty and one
shiny the rusty one you can see here
when it gets exposed to water it becomes
actually wet the water gets absorbed
into all the little pits and grooves
when the shiny one gets wet the water
just beads off it really easy it dries
out much faster which means it's exposed
to water for less time mere polishing
the steel is a great way to protect it
from corrosion but I'm going to take it
a step further and I'm gonna blew this
deal this is the same process we use for
protecting gun parts it's gonna turn it
a darker black color and put this
impervious non-corrosive surface all
over this deal gonna make it look pretty
slick as well and I'm gonna use a
chemical process to do that
okay step one I'm gonna apply some of
this rust remover and degreaser and I'm
going to apply it to the inside of the
eye here because this is a little bit of
rust here
[Music]
it's kind of nice it's turning black but
not like this even black it kind of this
this antique looking black alright that
looks pretty sick I'm really happy with
how that turned out
while that perma blew on the axe head is
curing I'm going to go ahead and start
working on the axe handle and I've got
this piece of laminated zebra wood here
which is absolutely stunning my friend
Matt help me laminate this a while back
since I don't have the equipment for
this and I'm excited this is going to is
going to be special
[Music]
well we're getting close but I gotta
stop for dinner and I will pick this up
a little bit later well it's day three
of this project I just got home from
work and it's a balmy 100 degrees
outside
so I'm getting ready to get started and
there's a thunderstorm coming so I've
got to take my setup here get it in the
garage if we're gonna get any work done
today Jacob
well I got the axe head fitted on now I
just need to finish off the handle looks
like Mother Nature is going to give me a
little bit of a fireworks show I do it
Jill
[Music]
well it doesn't look too bad but it's
time now to do a lot of sanding
[Music]
holy time
well it's been an hour and a half of
standing with the 120-grit time to
repeat the process with like some 600
grit 1200 grit 2,000 grit maybe some
3000 grit let's do it yeah it's all
smooth we're coating everything and a
lots and lots of linseed oil the fun
thing about boiled linseed oil is it
acts as a lubricant when it's fresh but
when it dries it gets sticky so it helps
get the axe head on when it's fresh it's
a lubricant but then after a few days
when it dries out it gets sticky and
keeps that head in place keeps the wedge
from coming out this is the part that
makes me the most nervous but I hit this
wedge wrong and break it off it can
cause me all sorts of problems nice and
even see if it goes down any further
[Music]
all right got a little wedge here one
thing nice about using these exotic
woods is they're very dried and aged so
they don't shrink at all in a matter of
fact when you add all the oil and stuff
they tend to expand a little bit and get
a little bit tighter with time so
hopefully this will stay on for a nice
long time
should we make a sheet so we don't cut
ourselves not you
[Music]
all right let's see see if I did it
right
[Music]
[Applause]
let's put on see how it goes there we go
get the sheath all dyed and coated in
beeswax and the beeswax kind of soaks in
and helps make it water repellent so to
get snow to rain on it won't rot as
easily
what do you think Nathan pretty Wow
let's watch your fingers
Lily get that yeah that's that's pretty
cool I'll keep that thing around for a
long time well I can't do an axe
restoration video and not do some chop
it so let's give it a go and see what
happens you don't want me to chop it up
[Music]
okay you don't want me to chop that up
yeah okay I'll leave it alone well guys
I hope you enjoyed watching this video
as much as I did making it if you want
to see more axe restoration and tool
restoration videos check our playlist
down in the video description and don't
forget to click subscribe we put out new
videos every Saturday morning if you
liked this video don't forget to check
out the outdoor boys youtube channel
where we have hundreds of videos just
like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning and hit
that Bell button so you'll get
notifications thanks for watching
[Music]